hello everyone
so today i'm going to record a different
kind of video as you can see here
so a few weeks ago uh i came across this
really nice video prepared by one of my
students
so when i say my student i don't just
mean it in a generic sense that he is a
student of the mechanical engineering
department here at iit kharagpur where
i'm a faculty
rather i mean it in the sense that he
was actually one of my students
in a class
that i was teaching in the previous year
in the autumn semester of 2020. so i was
sharing this class with another teacher
for i taught for half a semester so
taran was very much there in my class it
was an online class uh
i did not get to meet him face to face
but i do remember him very much uh
him being there in the online classes so
uh
so as you can see this video has uh has
gotten a lot of views
a huge number of views and uh i just
took a look around and i found that
tarun is actually one of the rising
superstars in the youtube landscape
and
so
because it is receiving so many views i
thought that
i'll respond to this especially because
there are certain things which he has
said
which i just can't be on the same page
with i'm sorry i mean i just can't be
uh
now my initial reaction uh since uh well
this is not really in the strictest
terms of the word a reaction video
because i have watched this video a
couple of times before um before make
before recording this this one
uh so this is not properly a reaction
video uh anyway
my first reaction when i did watch this
for the first time was that
oh my god where did you learn to edit
like this
and i'm sure anyone who watches this
video will have the same reaction
but at the same time my reaction
initially was that
uh oh my god please stop
just talk i can't bear this i was pissed
off
okay my initial reaction was that i was
pissed off frustrated
i can't believe what he's saying
however i i kept my patience i am a
teacher i'm supposed to be patient so
uh so i kept watching the video and by
the time i reached the end
i realized that uh
i think
what some of the things which uh tarun
said
uh
does make sense he has made some valid
points
uh
and i think i i mean i'm suspecting here
that he has said some things which are
kind of unpalatable
in a slightly clickbaity fashion okay so
he has uh
said those things so i'll take the bait
and i'll try to respond so uh without
speaking further
let's just look at the video
hey friends if you're new here my name
is taran and i'm a fourth year student
in the department of mechanical
engineering at iit kharagpur
and in this video i'll be sharing my
three years experience being a
mechanical engineering undergrad in
india so by the end of this video if you
are someone in your 11th or 12th you'll
get a perfect clarity on whether you
should consider a degree in mechanical
engineering and if you're already in
your college and are in the first or
second year and are in a core department
like mechanical you'll get to know all
the career opportunities that you have
in the future so watch the video till
then let's go
so
anyone who is watching this
video for the first time i would really
really advise them to take uh tharon's
word here
please do watch this video till the very
end okay
[Music]
[Music]
was that really necessary
really
this is bad
so before a few days my fourth day
classes started and one of the props is
no one will fail in this course
attendance is not mandatory you can
directly come for the exam and everyone
will pass in this exam this is because
this course is getting removed from the
curriculum next year see that's how
irrelevant the courses have become no
no that's not the thing oh my god
so
so he has gotten this all wrong
so
and no matter i mean this is not a fake
reaction okay so every time i watch this
part of the video
and i have watched this like three or
four times now
so he doesn't know it probably
that
the entire curriculum
not just in the mechanical engineering
department but
overall through iit kharagpur has been
completely
overhauled
okay so we did this exercise in 2019-20
sorry 2020 it was completely overhauled
like right from the first year till the
fourth year and the fifth year courses
and currently we are going to the to the
masters level so the undergraduate
revision has already taken place uh in
2020 and what has happened as a result
is that
we
we realized that some of the courses
which were being taught in the third
year for example mechanics of solids
are needed to be brought to the second
year
so and some of the courses which were
there uh in a separated fashion they had
to be clubbed together and some of the
courses which were which were there like
in one big chunk they had to be
separated out maybe as a as a as a
compulsory subject and as an elective
and some of the subjects had to be made
elective because they are more
specialized so those kinds of very very
granulated
discussions and decisions were made
which is why
as part of the administration logistics
some of these subjects are going to be
discontinued not in the sense that the
subjects are going to be discontinued
rather those course numbers which these
students are studying this they are
going to be discontinued and they are
going to be continued in a different
form with us with the new course number
with a completely overhauled syllabus
updated syllabus
uh
keeping in uh keeping in terms with the
global standards uh
uh from from the junior batches and that
has that exercise has actually started
so uh
speaking about mechanics of solids which
i teach
[Music]
their uh
what they studied
uh
at the third year level has been
completely changed and now i'm teaching
it at the second year level
that is at par with
some of the best
syllabus which is being followed abroad
and i think this is uh i think this this
is uh more in keeping with what is being
taught across all the iits also uh all
the older ideas so uh i think this is a
very good step and not a retrograde step
as tarun has made it out to be okay
like this is the most general equation
for the distortion energy theory
yes
yes that is the distortion energy theory
and that is very much part of mechanics
of solids and although for their batch i
did not teach that my colleague was
teaching it uh
so so let him say
seriously
like what will i even do with that
do you think the equation is going to be
useful in my entire life like look at
all these courses
yes it is going to be important for your
uh entire life if you actually become a
mechanical engineer similarly it is
going to be important if you are a civil
engineer or an aerospace engineer or a
naval architecture or an engineer from
the naval architect architecture
department it is going to be absolutely
important in fact it is so very
important the distortion energy theory
especially within the context of failure
theories that if you do not respect it
the things that you make will break
apart and people's lives will be lost
so
in case that was not clear during the
classes i am making it clear now
so
so there there's that
here's my third semester here is the
fourth he's the fifth and this is the
sixth and i've successfully mugged up
all the formulas and theories i've
scored good enough
so he's not actually lying so i know
tarun uh
he's
certainly one of
our good students uh i wouldn't say he's
a topper but he's certainly one of her
good students uh he he consistently gets
more than decent grades
and
i i believe him that when he says that
he has marked up the formulas although
it is
i'm sure he he doesn't mug up the
formulas because if you just mug up the
formulas you would not be getting uh
grades as good as you are getting so you
do learn
you have i i really i really want to
believe that you have actually learned
those formulas
properly
but i don't remember any of this right
now
like why will i even remember what's the
point i'll remember something if i ever
feel that it would be helpful for me at
some point of my life but now with
negligible amount of companies coming to
hearts
okay so he has made a good point here
he has remembered these formulas for the
sake of examinations and uh
he doesn't remember this formula well
guess what i taught this course i don't
remember the formula
okay i was a student i was one of
uh
well
i was a very good student of course uh
which is why i end up becoming a faculty
member here
uh
and i'm teaching this course for a few
years now even i don't remember this
myself i'm supposed to be the teacher
the expert here so we are not supposed
to remember these formulas all the time
it's one thing to appear in the
examination where you need to have
certain things in your fingertips so
that you can apply those things in a
very quick fashion
but
as a as a lifelong exercise you are not
supposed to remember these things
it doesn't make any sense i mean we have
a finite amount of space in our head if
you keep on remember everything every
little detail then we are never going to
learn anything new that's not how the
brain works
so
we do not expect you to remember
everything of course when when it
when the turn comes by the grand vibe or
the comprehensive wi-fi as i have made
clear
in a separate video i'll link to that
here
you will need to ha take a strategy
effort to to to revise those things but
beyond these things at any any given
point of time nobody remembers this you
don't need that so you're absolutely
right so if you need to
uh need to remember this learn this
later you can just look it up absolutely
but
what students do not understand is that
at a very young stage if they do not go
through the exercise of learning these
things not mugging up the formula mind
you if they do not learn these things
the connections in their brain never get
made
and if the if it doesn't get made at a
younger stage it will never get made
when you become older so when you're in
your late 20s or early 30s no matter how
much effort you put the kind of
uh
like bedrock foundational connections
which you will make as a as a student in
your in your
as as a as maybe 19 year or 20 year old
student
the kind of foundational connections
that gets created in your brain
that will never get made which is why it
is important so very important to to
learn the things in a proper fashion
when you are young
you can learn things later on definitely
but the foundational connection will
never be made across different things
someone for a core job what do i do with
all these theories in the book when
everyone needs a person who can code why
does this department even exist you can
at least reduce the number of students
in these departments it's all about
supply and demand so he is right about
this point so
the number of jobs
in mechanical core
is
certainly less than in the circuit
branches
well if it is not less it is less pain
certainly
so
uh a an average student
nowadays uh taking up a software kind of
job uh
would have a higher chance
of or would have a chance of getting a
higher pay compared to a court job
unless of course he's going to an
hardcore really hardcore mechanical
engineering job like in one of the very
big companies like well-established comp
companies which are like century like
like maybe 50 years old maybe 100 years
old that kind of very established
companies and they do exist companies
like that
in the startup scenario uh
you will not get such kind of companies
in mechanical core as compared to uh in
the in the software
side
okay so he is right in the sense that if
we do not have such a huge demand why
keep
uh
such a i mean
i mean mechanical engineering department
here at iit kharagpur is the biggest
department so why keep
so high a number of students so that is
something which needs to be debated on
and i agree with uh tarun in the sense
uh
that some some thought needs to be put
into this uh on a on a on a higher level
uh
policy kind of way and
please note that this is something not
which
which
neither i nor my colleagues in the
department can
take
this decision overnight
so
all
man right when there's negligible demand
for mechanical engineers in the society
why would you still give admissions to
so many students in this department and
you might be wondering why do they even
choose mechanical engineering then i
don't know don't i don't know
actually yeah right so as as a 20 year
old
kid
i do not expect taran to to to fully
appreciate the gravitas of the situation
what society needs is not a huge number
of mechanical engineers that is true
that is absolutely true we do not need
the absolutely huge number of mechanical
engines like perhaps we need uh
something like that in the software
industry
so
uh run-of-the-mill uh mechanical
engineers
they would have a hard time however the
society needs very good mechanical
engineers okay
like the society will completely break
down if we do not have very very good
mechanical engineers so also uh civil
engineers aerospace engineers uh
electrical engineers okay i mean the
society completely like like collapse
without these engineers but the very
good engineers
i was 17 i was really good at physics so
i thought mechanical engineering is the
way to go and to be honest in iits you
don't decide which branch you will get
your rank determines which branch you
will get and this case is not only with
me but many of my friends also but
finally when i was entering my third
year that's when i got to know that i
picked up so for all my juniors who are
yet to enter the college i request you
to prefer circuit branches over
departments like mechanical chemical if
you are taking
so what is said here uh and also also
the guy from i think kanpur uh
it is true
so when we are in that 17 year old 18
year old at the threshold of iit after
after finishing our uh after uh
successfully completing je
we
uh we just look at the counselling
brochure and look at the
the
the ranks
which in in which the students had uh
filled up the various departments so it
was the same in my case back in 2004 so
uh i also took the took a look at the
counseling brochure look at the range of
ranks where people were
uh we're getting into the various
departments and i chose likewise uh
so the only other thing was that i i am
from a very middle class family like a
very middle class family so uh
i talk to my parents uh my dad kind of
told me like neither my mom nor my dad
they and please note that this is like
what uh 17 years ago now
oh my god it has been that long so uh
back then nobody of us knew none of my
family knew anything about this thing uh
i didn't even know what was taught in
mechanical engineering when i took it so
as taran said he was good in physics so
he took mechanical engineering so i
thought the same kind of things i was
good in maths and physics uh i heard
that i mean you get to do a lot of maths
and physics in mechanical engineering so
it should be a good thing plus
mechanical engineering is core it's
evergreen so how bad could it be
so it turned out it's not so bad
okay i have stuck with mechanical
entering all my life this is my life now
so
well that is my case uh but i can
understand what tyron is saying here
efficient in some good colors like iits
nights or bits
no matter which department you take you
can always learn dsa and get a good
placement but if you are taking
admission in normal colors there is no
point to choose
almost all my batchmates in mechanical
engineering department try for non-core
placements most of them start learning
dsas from the first year of the college
and try for internships and placements
in software or data these companies
don't care about your department all
they care about is how well you can code
and if you have any projects in this
domain one of my seniors from mechanical
engineering department
okay so up to this point he has said
some very important things uh
correct absolutely i agree with him
it's a fact that many of the students
when they
when they come to the department
the second year students in mechanical
engineering they immediately start
learning how to code properly how to as
it says dsa data structures and
algorithms uh and there's a craze about
python learning python and i appreciate
this okay so there is this market demand
huge market demand for such kind of uh
skills and the students need to get a
job at the end of the day so if there is
a greater demand for those kinds of jobs
and they're taking such students why not
prepare accordingly so i fully stand
behind that kind of a thing so there was
a time when
there was a kind of resistance in our
department
against students
i mean taking this kind of choices but i
think the attitude has changed now in
the sense that we we all appreciate the
the market pull up
and and the need for students to prepare
accordingly
however he has also said something
extremely important that if you are
going to iit to nit
to bits then there is a great
opportunity for you both from among your
peers as well as
because of the overall environment that
you find in those uh really really good
places uh
to
to take up these kinds of things
learning dsa on your own with the help
of your friends
with the numerous opportunities various
societies are here
when i say society these are like
student groups
and
you can you can
i mean chart out your career as you want
it to be however if you are going to a
not such a such a great place and there
are certain colleges like that in india
as well as i'm sure abroad also
then
yeah you should be really really
serious about mechanical engineering uh
like
uh
you really have to love it and i think
this is a point which thurin makes later
on in the video also like you really
really have to love mechanical
engineering you need to have the
mentality to stick to it okay otherwise
opportunities uh
are going to be hard to come by
uh so he's going to say something about
one of his seniors now
got placed for 60 lpa last year as a
software engineer and talking about rod
okay i think uh i i know the guy he is
talking about the 60 lpa guy
so
this is a one-off case
okay this is a one-off case
that kind of a
package or that kind of a profile the
student got
he
he is the kind of guy who
who really really got into it very early
okay and mind you he this is this is
maybe so his history is
tracking back let's say
uh
probably five years uh before so
when there was this fresh thrust into
taking engineers as data scientists uh
he he tapped into that that uh that
fresh that initial thrust so he got into
that
but that doesn't mean that
there are many other students in his
batch also who were similarly learning
the stuff
uh dsa but who did not end up with that
kind of a package
okay so we have to remember and
appreciate that so that was a very
special one of case
alex this video is sponsored by code
damn so poddam is a platform where
students can learn to code by building
projects and getting expert feedback it
has interactive playground
so i think we can i mean
fast forward this thing a little bit
so students
even unders a lot more
who is aiming for a software engineer
more profiles other than software or
data analytics that my classmates
prepare for if you have them try for
placements in consultancy finance or
product and the average package is
actually good and only a very few
students prepare for court lessons
okay so he has said some other profiles
and it is actually true also so those
kinds of things probably on the
management side of the finance side
they have so the history uh behind them
is slightly older than this data science
thing and uh back when we were students
uh the
the kind of packages uh people with
those kinds of profiles we're getting
certainly higher and that is i think uh
the norm all over the world
so
as an engineer if you are veering into
the finance side then the package will
be higher but at the same time i have
also heard from many of my friends who
went to those kinds of lines that after
the initial
enthusiasm has worn off
well
they end up not liking it very much okay
because
uh
i mean you will
never
enjoy your work
uh
very much if the only attraction of your
job is just the money i mean money is
great i completely agree with it okay
if you don't have enough money i mean no
amount of philosophizing or
saying big big things is going to matter
so that is important
but if that is the only thing in your
job
then you are not going to be happy
this is mainly because there are less
opportunities and even the companies
which come provide less packages people
say that there's exponential growth
after you get the job but i don't know
so he is now talking about the core jobs
and as i have already said earlier
initially if you join a core job in a
hardcore industry in an average hardcore
company
hardcore means a mechanical core company
the
pay package is going to be less
so
that is there is a fact of life which
you have to accept okay
and what it says that i don't know
whether there is going to be an
exponential growth
after that initial less salary
that is true you never know
okay it could be that after that initial
low salary you get to rise so fast in
the company that you end up with a like
an exponential carrier growth in terms
of pay packages also that that gets
reflected in your pay package but uh you
can't rely on that
okay
now let's talk about opportunities other
than college placements or private
sector jobs see if you're
so this is the favorite part of my video
okay in mechanical engineering
department and are really passionate
about it you can go for higher studies
or research there are exams conducted by
barc is so every year and if you can
crack them
that's it
yeah
so
it seems tarun has a habit of
exaggerating when he says bad things he
really crushes them when he says good
things he really props them up so it is
certainly true that uh there are great
opportunities in israel park uh of the
places so but it's not so golden as he's
setting is he's putting it that if if
you if you get into history back your
life is set when you have to keep on
working very very hard there uh and
there is an upper limit to the kind of
packages you'll end up getting there
also but
what he's what he's saying in uh i mean
if you interpret his verse tarun's words
in the sense that your life is set in
terms of the technical quality of the
job that you'll get to do well then yes
absolutely okay the kind of things that
they get to do
well that's a proper engineer's job
okay
that's a proper engineer's job they are
real engineers okay so
hats off to them any any day and please
note that in in israel you know you'll
not find many iits so recently uh one of
my students my master students he joined
israel and he was ecstatic okay
and
he had to go through a gruelling uh
interview procedure like he had to
really really study hard for that so
there's that okay so it's not easy
getting into israel uh it's not easy
getting into bulk
furthermore uh
if you are really really interested so
some of the top students of our of our
department what they do every year is
that they go for higher studies to usa
to europe uh
and
in terms of research in mechanical
engineering
well
i mean
it's just wonderful there okay because
as a mechanical engineer you can go into
different different streams like
uh i cannot even tell you and that's
that requires a separate video
altogether for me to tell you about the
opportunities in in higher studies and
research okay uh you can go into the
completely mathematical side uh of
things which uh i kind of did myself you
can go into the experimental side of
things which is very hardcore practical
mechanical engineering application
you can go into interdisciplinary things
which is kind of an admixture between
mechanical and electronics mechanical
and chemical uh
i mean i'm putting mechanical aerospace
and civil altogether okay uh you can you
know even go into
certain things in physics engineering
physics particularly
you can go into
uh
into
things which are amalgamated with
computer science so it's a wonderful
world out there okay
so
if you're really interested in higher
studies and if you have the grades to
back it up and the passion
well
i would say mechanical engineering is
the best like absolutely the best
like
if if i knew that i
would end up
uh
doing higher studies as i as i did then
i would have gone back to
the
to myself of 2004 when i was choosing
mechanical engineering and i would have
given him a pat on the back that well
done
okay well done we have taken mechanical
engineering
live set a few of my classmates are
planning to appear for gate so that they
can go for mtech in good college or get
into psus like phl and tpc etc and there
are engineering services exams which you
can always go for so finally what i am
trying to say is that if you are really
passionate about something and can work
your ass off for that you will be able
to succeed no matter what the
circumstances are so even if you have a
mechanical engineering department if you
can be the top most student in the class
no one can stop you
but the question is are you willing to
work that hard
or are you looking for an easy way out
thank you
so that is and that is that this is the
reason this last piece was the reason
why i have asked why i have requested
everyone at the beginning to watch it
till the very end
okay so if you are willing to work hard
and be passionate about it then uh there
are golden opportunities waiting for you
in mechanical engineering
okay so
uh
and with that being said if you want to
know about my first year experience in
the college watch this video on the
right
all right so we are at the end uh
and uh needless to say it is a very very
well made video okay so congrats on that
thorough you have done it done a really
wonderful job in creating the video uh
and i think the kind of things which you
have said at till the very end i mean
overall the overall message of this if
everyone looks at it uh completely and
not just in pieces
then i think the message here is
positive
okay so thank you for that
it was fun responding to this video all
right
and all the best to you for your fourth
year